you can say that laplace
is somebody asking a question
we can say that what that question
involves is
his future answer itself
then there can be the answer he
gives and there can be reality and if
basically if laplace's questions of the
form will i not be thinking that the
answer is yes one second from now
whatever answer he gives now you can set
up in such a way that his answer to his
question will actually be the opposite
of the truth
and it doesn't matter what kind of a
system he uses to make that future
prediction it doesn't matter if the
paradigm in which he was working
of classical non-chaotic finite physics
was correct
his
demon is in this very formal very broad
sense going to be wrong
he as a demon will be wrong and there
will still be instances of such
erroneousness
even if he builds a um uh demon that
goes off and makes the prediction on his
behalf so if it's not laplace's demon
it's not the plus is the demon he makes
it even the same kind of thing goes
through so that's the way that we can
actually formalize the very simple
notion of laplace this is demon is a
flawed concept in its very
presumption it's very structured
independent of the rules of reality
in such a way that actually allows us to
then derive things like the monotheism
theorem
and the deism theorem and these other
things about how many omnipotent
entities might a physical reality have
independent of the laws of physics it
sounds like what you said is that there
exists a question such that he will
necessarily be incorrect so when i was
first reading about this i thought that
it was going to go along the lines of
there exists configurations of physical
space such that he won't necessarily be
correct but you're saying no there's a
question such that he will necessarily
be wrong no matter what no matter what
question answer pair
he comes up with it will be wrong if it
is supposed to be related to physical
reality remember there are three things
there's your question your answer and
then whatever the truth of the matter is
and so there are ways of setting up that
though that tripled i say i see so
that we can be guaranteed
that um if that question answer in
reality is supposed to be something that
concerns the future state of his brain
then um no matter what the details are
we can always
set up a question in such a way that the
answer
will not actually be the same thing as
reality says but will be the opposite